aussie media has announced they would be
shutting down on friday so we thought
today we'd talk about that shutdown but
this morning their ceo had a change of
heart on nbc's today show which put him
on air
in what is
one of the more deranged uh
you know
narcissistic
uh interviews i've ever seen i mean this
would be like in my mind like elizabeth
holmes and bernie madoff
doing an interview like the week after
they did their perp walk it's bonkers
so just to give you a brief recap the
new york times ben smith who is a media
reporter who came from buzzfeed
who was involved in a lot of deals and
now he's kind of like
a columnist having formerly been a
senior executive so it's his position is
really murky like the fact that they
allow him to use all this previous
information he had from his previous
life and
it would be like some venture capitalist
or president of a company that decided
to be a columnist and used all the
inside information they had to write
columns it's it's pretty entertaining
ben smith is a a good read and and so
much so ben smith is so conflicted that
many times when he publishes a piece he
has to put like a disclaimer paragraph
that like yeah i was involved in this
company i negotiated with this company i
have a deal with that company i did i
still own shares in buzzfeed i'm trying
to clear them i'm trying to i mean he is
conflicted all over the place um which
makes it even more entertaining as we
say in the industry no conflict no
interest and man ben smith is so
conflicted it's super interesting uh the
quote from the article about his
conflict which you know listen he's up
front about it so i think pretty easy to
say that he's covered his bases in that
regard quote i was an editor-in-chief of
buzzfeed news at the time of the article
later i met mr watson when i was
peripherally involved in acquisition
talks between the companies in other
words
ben smith is writing about this company
that he was involved in
you know merging with i guess or buying
mr watson told the times he believed
that it was unethical for me to write
this column under new york times policy
i can't write about buzzfeed extensively
until i divest stock options in the
company which i left last year so i
guess extensively is the a key word in
there but the new york times you know
like
i think their ethics uh policies are
pretty strong about this kind of stuff
but i think they're also
becoming a little loosey-goosey as
they've picked their side right they've
just gone full woke full
you know i would say socialist left you
know social democratic as opposed to
really trying to be unbiased in their
approach right they literally are hiring
journalists
to
a whole tech accountable and they're
doing press releases saying hey we're
going to hold tech accountable so
pretty interesting approach by the new
york times and it's obviously working to
get the more subscribers so i don't have
a problem with it as long as they're
upfront about it so last week there were
allegations that aussie was inflating
their metrics uh you know through pop
unders and other
uh you know gray hat or black hat tricks
uh and then they would use those
puffed up numbers to raise money and
then of course you know that there was
an fbi
or there apparently is an fbi
investigation
into them impersonating a youtube
executive on a call with goldman to
raise 40 million dollars after the
article came out there was a board
investigation uh that was announced
uh and ozzie's most popular uh recently
hired uh broadcaster kdk resigned it's
been like this whole everyday you know a
couple of shoes drop uh and we've just
got a pile of shoes right now in the
friday news dump right always drop your
news on friday ozzie announced they were
going to wind down operations and shut
down so this is what i said last week
the company's obviously going to go to
zero it's going to shut down it's
it's always obvious to me because i've
seen this movie before no investors want
to touch a company like this no
investors are going to make money
you know if they could make money they
would right there's just no money to be
made when a company is under
investigation or by the fbi or goldman
sachs was uh defrauded uh you know
during a call like it's just these are
insurmountable odds so fast forward to
today monday friday they're shutting
down carlos watson went on the today
show and announced that ozzy would be
staying open
called it a lazarus moment uh so i guess
he's kind of saying jesus is gonna
resuscitate him and bring him back to
life
this is uh pretty crazy um and
these videos to me and i hate to
uh play amateur psychologists here
but this is the craziest narcissistic
performance i've seen since elizabeth
holmes i'll see you on the other side of
this 40-second
train wreck
let's start with the status of ozzie as
we sit right now reports that the
company shut down on friday is that true
is the company shut down or are you
still open for business you know we're
going to open for business so uh we're
making news today uh this is our lazarus
moment if you will this is our tylenol
moment
last week was traumatic it was difficult
um heartbreaking in many ways and at the
end of the week we did suspend
operations with a plan to wind down but
as we spent time over the weekend we
talked to advertising partners we talk
to some of our readers from our viewers
our listeners our investors i think
ozzy's is part of this moment and it's
not going to be easy
but i think what we do with newsletters
what we do with tv shows original tv
shows podcasts and more i think as a
place this is uh
crazy behavior because he literally is
making himself into a victim here that
like
nobody asked you if last week was hard
you guys are involved in
clearly criminal behavior
of
like securities fraud like this is
deranged behavior and you're talking
about how hard last week was
i mean
nobody has any sympathy for you and then
this level of grandiosity of like
we
are this is like important for him to
you know be out there and uh defending
himself
it really is crazy
this is an
absolutely crazy narcissistic person
from my professional opinion of dealing
with founders that's just my
professional assessment
i have seen founders who have
uh delusions of grandeur i have seen
people who um
cannot acknowledge when they're wrong
and then there's like another level so
like you can be delusional
i want i'm the greatest angel investor
of all time i want to be the greatest
angel investor uh in the history of
silicon valley like these are grandiose
things i've said that i set as a goal
for myself
but
he'll also acknowledge that there's like
five angel investors that we all know
who have done massively better than me
and i always say like you know they're
kind of retired so maybe i have a shot
at being number one maybe i'll be mount
rushmore
and then there are people who want to
get to mars or there are people who
um you know want to index the world's
data like google like people set
stretch goals and then there's
like uh
this deranged
sense of self-importance do you get that
self-importance like nobody cares about
aussie media nobody cares if ozzie
exists
the right thing to do here when all this
behavior has happened much of which
seems criminal um and seems like it
would be securities fraud is to shut the
thing down and say we made mistakes
we're gonna put this thing to bed you
know and hopefully i'll earn people's
trust back but
this is nuts
all right it's time for another r crowd
deal of the week right now you can join
our crowd's investment in consumer
physics according to the deal memo
consumer physics has developed the first
portable lab-grade device that can
analyze material at a molecular level
this helps farmers boost production
improve efficiency and minimize waste
consumer physics has grown revenue 100
year over year and is used by over 50
global enterprise customers according to
their deal memo so speaking of growth do
you wish you were in early on some of
the best performing ipos of 2019 and
2020 well our crowd investors were and
now you can join them with our crowd
accredited investors can invest directly
easily and most importantly early yes
our crowd investors have already
benefited from companies ipo like beyond
me or being bought by companies like
intel nike microsoft oracle and uber
my favorite of course our crowd's
accredited investors have already
invested over one billion dollars in
growing tech companies if you are an
accredited investor you can join our
crowd for free at ourcrowd.com
twist and then you get to review all
those current deal memos and that's a
free education right there deal memos
are a great way to get really smart
really fast there's no payment involved
until you decide to invest that's
rcrout.com
twist to sign up for free